you can't look at it in a vacuum and
just say American slaves why have the
same suicide rate they didn't have the
same kind of abuse from within their
family all right I am I'm glad to have
our next guest on the program you can
follow on Twitter at Julie ray now Julie
ray goldstein is actually a known
actress verified blue checkmark on the
Twitter as long as they're still giving
those out and allowing people to keep
those right now and has made it a point
to obviously criticize go after this
program quite a bit on Twitter and we've
been sort of missing each other but
you're on the show now Julie ray
goldstein thanks for being here oh
thanks for having me Steven I actually
really appreciate that you're willing to
have a conversation really you sound
surprised
ah no I'm not surprised I think at in
this current political environment I
think people are too polarized in one
way or another and I like actually
reaching out and looking at other points
of view so I'm kind of used to people
being a little more combative sure you
can come across coming coming a little
hot on Twitter so maybe that's why they
might seem competitive combative but
listen I I appreciate it in let me ask
you this I guess before we kind of
continue with a conversation what what
is it that you think would be fruitful
what are you open to glean kind of from
us sitting down here oh absolutely I
think the thing that interests me the
most is making sure that your audience
is aware of the actual science behind
some of the things that you've said in
the past sure um I think we both come
into it from a scientific perspective we
both want the best for people I don't
think either of us has malicious intent
in any regard but I think there's been a
bit of MIS association or
misinterpreting or misquoting Mis citing
the science okay so I just wanted to
clarify that okay well first off by the
way I did mention verified actress and
blue checkmark but I should say
transgender individual and activist sure
in case in case people didn't know
today's topic will be transgenderism and
obviously we've got into the science
quite a bit with our audience it's not
something that we that we hide from them
we certainly don't try to keep people in
the dark but yeah let's let's start with
that then where do you think I know
you've criticized me in a few different
areas in this program and it really more
so people who line up with my worldview
as a whole on the current transgender
issue
do you think it is that that we've we've
gotten this wrong well I think the first
part that I've criticized you a lot is
you mentioned you did a segment on what
was it like Timmy the bear I'm aware you
said something about how trans people
post-surgery can't experience sexual
pleasure can't orgasm and you said it at
one point with Ben Shapiro as well
that's actually completely incorrect I
can tell you as someone who has had
surgery and still experiences sexual
pleasure and orgasms that that's not the
typical response I there's actually
studies that show that over eighty
percent remain orgasmic post-surgery
and okay so that's that's one of you
well first off I do want to make sure
that we're clear on a couple things
something that's talked about with Timmy
the bear isn't necessarily meant to be a
reputable study but we have discussed
yeah for example I think on the
understood what struck me I don't
remember the Timmy the bear but I
remember in the I'm just a bill parody
it was many transgenders never
experienced sexual pleasure again now if
I've ever said definitively that no
transgenders ever after sexual
reassignment therapy can ever have
orgasms yeah that would be incorrect but
no I I appreciate that there are studies
though quite a few that show that for
example men a hundred percent of men
experience orgasm
cisgender men to use for the
nomenclature that's out there nowadays
those who transition transgenders it's
as low as 65% so it still is a 35%
decrease and the point that I was making
with that is you know listen if you knew
there was a 35% chance at that point if
there was thirty five percent thirty
five out of a hundred chance that you
won't ever be able to experience an
orgasm again would that lend to the
suicidality to the morbidity to the
mortality rates that you see in the
transgender community I know for me if I
knew that I was never going to achieve
sexual climax again I put a nine
millimeter in my mouth so that was the
point that that that we were making no
in the same here too I'm very vocal
about how I'm a huge horror nerd but the
thing that like I can't do in Hoorn I
think this is where this came out is the
sequence in The Handmaid's Tale that got
me the most is the female genital
mutilation scene and I cannot watch that
in horror even though I love for love
Eli Roth grew up with horror but it's
it's this idea that trans people have
gone through so much to reclaim their
sexuality and their
you'll pleasure that the idea of
somebody taking that away no believe me
it would make me want to put a
nine-millimeter in my mouth - if I knew
that yes but I question where you're
bringing up that 65% I'd actually like
to see the citations on that because I
actually like to look at that in kind of
what I tell people is here some studies
look at the science we don't actually
read it make up the decision for
yourself well the science you can't
really make up the decision but you know
go from there but if you're not sure
people can cherry-pick studies and
that's why I met analyses are very
important and of course the parameters
of scientific studies that's why
double-blind placebo-controlled clinical
trials are considered the gold standard
as opposed to just a general study that
says hey our supplemental formula works
go take it you know and who's funding
the studies but ya know science is
science but of course there's a way to
manipulate how it's presented through an
agenda yeah here's what we will do
because I obviously it wouldn't be fair
for me to bring up studies and do them
as an overlay as you're doing this and
you don't have the ability but we will
when we upload this video
everything that I'm referencing will be
available put them in links they're
available on PubMed so yeah it's about
65% okay um I'd actually like to see
that because the one that I I looked at
here actually it pretty much it does say
a large number of transsexuals 80%
reported improvement of their sexuality
now here's the thing majority of
participants reported a change in Oh
orgasmic feeling so it differs and
because of brain differences actually
the orgasm I this is just my feeling and
kind of on my experience the orgasm that
you have after surgery feels more right
and is more let's say it it it it's more
pleasurable and more it it it affects
you differently yeah I remember having
an orgasm like pre surgery and then you
could imagine I'm slightly uncomfortable
with this territory now I was well know
this is anecdotal you're talking about
how you feel during orgasms which I
appreciate and I hope it's fantastic I
wish you nothing but the best but I
don't necessarily know that that helps
the people watching right now so yeah
we'll get this information up there for
people who want to watch it I know I
know there are several other areas where
you
sighs me and the program is there
anywhere else where you think we get the
science glaringly wrong absolutely
you've also said that suicidality is the
same priam post surgery that's actually
just found to be false in multiple
different studies that actually use the
same methodology pre and post mm-hmm I'm
quoting there's one study here from
Belgium that a cauldron yeah I think you
quote one study from Belgium and one
study from Canada quite a bit if I'm not
mistaken but yeah let's go yeah there's
one from Belgium from 2006 that actually
shows that it drops from 29.3% 25.1% the
study from Canada actually shows 27.1 to
1% the study that actually you bring up
a lot is a doctored ahead Janee study
the one from Sweden which actually
doesn't quite say what you think it does
and this let me actually use dr.
jeannette Jenni's words herself she
actually says that the study as a whole
that she did covers a period between
1973 and 2003 what she found is that
when she divided the cohorts into two
groups 1973 to 1980 Oh on your mic this
muted on us one second oh I don't want
people to think that we're doing evil
internet overlords censorship of you we
can't hear you we lost sound oh oh now
you're back you're back sorry go ahead
okay take it from the top no and let
everyone know nothing up my sleeves it
was just an internet issue okay go ahead
no yeah um so doctor the head and he
found that if she divided the cohorts
into 1973 to 1988 and 1989 to 2003
obviously methodology diagnostic tools
change procedures change but she found
that if she divided at the differences
in mortality suicide attempts and crime
actually disappear and found no
different criminality or suicidality
than the cisgender controls for the 1989
to 2003 group there are a couple things
it's not just a suite of study though
that's an important one and it's not
exactly how you're presenting it but I
would like to before we do that because
I appreciate you talking about one
Belgian study one Canadian study this is
important for people to know why do you
think that I would completely throw out
the study you're mentioning from Belgium
I honestly don't know I mean I think
some people have an agenda I don't think
you here's the thing okay why do you
think I would throw everyone from Canada
I um I I honestly don't know I go ahead
okay yeah well the study from Belgium
and this is one thing that I think is
very important because trans the
transgender community likes to say
you're denying the science quite a bit
and what they do is take exceptions to
the rule rather than the rule so there's
one Belgian study which was done a while
ago we've done far more studies with
greater sample sizes and better more
objective parameters since then it's
interesting to me too you just mentioned
a 30-point difference between your own
studies the Belgian study and the
Canadians any couple of reasons for that
the belgian study actually I think it
was 100 something people maybe 107
people who participated 43% of the
participants dropped out meaning we have
no idea what happened to them by the end
we have no idea if they're still alive
so 43% of people who started the study
were not included at the end of the
study only 62 I think I'd have 105 or
107 I don't have it in front of me right
now that distorts the number quite a bit
of course the Canadians those who don't
know the Canadian study debate only
study only so I will let me let me kind
of give you my macro and then if you
disagree that you can so that's one
study that's where you saw it go down
from 29% to I think 5 percent is what
you quoted and then you said a Canadian
study where it goes down to 1% well
that's a testicle E significant because
the variability there if it were in one
study it would have to be thrown out
you'd have to redraw this study up
because 30% and 1% is pretty big the
Canadian study studies one year it asks
people within the last year of their
surgery if they've attempted suicide so
a study where 43% of the people have
dropped out and then a study that only
asks people about one year is not the
same as a Swedish study that you
mentioned or another Canadian study
that's more recent that actually takes a
larger sample size 300 something people
over the course of many several decades
and studies objective parameters like
mortality like morbidity like
suicidality but mainly mortality are
they alive are they dead that's
objective on like the Belgian study
which is a questionnaire and 43% dropped
out when you look at those studies that
objectively frame and the parameters and
aren't by the way conducted by a pro
trans activist group as a Canadian study
which you and I both know come on it'd
be like a supplement company funding a
supplement research paper it's 19 to 8
times more likely for post-operative
transgenders to commit suicide across
bored in all the other studies across
the board it's between 16 and 19 times
more likely than general populace to
kill themselves well let me also make a
differentiation between those Canadian
and the Belgium studies the Belgium
study actually only studied people who
had surgery the Canadian Studies studied
people who who had stated that they were
done transitioning and for some people
that's not surgery so that's also
another factor I get again we're looking
at different methodologies which we
can't say are equivalent in any sort of
way but we also have a 2010
meta-analysis we could say one is more
valid right we do have to agree which
one's more valid one that's funded by
the trans pulse project that only asks
people in a questionnaire within the
last year or one that studies over 300
people and whether they died or not ones
right well I don't think we can see that
in the in a vacuum and we can't really
make distinctions let me give you an
example we can't make distinctions based
on mortality unless we're comparing the
same things pre and post huh oh sorry
your sound keeps going on again it's not
it's the evil overlords at YouTube they
this is there you go okay sorry canal
it's I yeah anyway so here's kind of a
comparative thing if we did a study of
people with cancer and gave them
chemotherapy and measured the mortality
of people with cancer after getting
chemotherapy and measured that against
assists Jen not cisgender a control of
people who didn't have cancer sure you
would find that the mortality rate would
be higher in the people who received
chemotherapy and had cancer but you
can't use that then to make a
distinction that chemotherapy doesn't
improve the chances of sort of less
mortality of people with cancer
shrieking not if you're comparing it to
people what up kid
well first off let me just establish
kind of the premises here which we're
discussing I think we both agree the
suicide rate is high among the
transgender community the attempted
suicide rate and if I'm not mistaken a
big criticism that you've had toward me
is that post-operative transgenders are
actually far less likely so what we're
talking about here what we are debating
is the idea that post-operative
transgenders have improved suicidality
rates so that's why I was discussing
these studies I I don't think there
needs to be any correction because again
let's say you took
that's that use your own example cancer
do you compare these patients who didn't
undergo chemo these people are 19 times
more likely to die if they do not
receive chemotherapy and then he gave
them chemotherapy and afterward you said
these people are 19 times more likely to
die than the general population even if
they've had chemotherapy it would be a
valid comparison so I'm addressing your
point that you've criticized this show
that you say it improves the suicide
rates it doesn't it doesn't and the
overwhelming number of studies that are
performed objectively using objective
parameters show that it doesn't unless
you cherry-pick studies for funded by
transgender activists and I just don't
think that that's a fair way to to
compare science and certainly to come on
someone's program or tell someone else
that you're going to inform them as to
the science again all these are in
PubMed people please go research yes
both your studies and my studies yeah
what we're talking about I mean I can
also quote you a 2010 meta-analysis of
28 different studies that show that 78%
of trans people showed an improvement of
psychiatric symptoms another study of 50
trans women who received genital surgery
that found that their physical mental
health was not significantly different
from samples of sis women I mean we have
yeah that's a question there's I need to
be I need to be really clear here it's
like people this is a big thing I have
with sort of socialists on health care
this is why Cubans think they have
better health care than Americans if you
ask someone do you think your health
care is better than United States and
they say yes it doesn't mean it's better
right our mortality rates are better our
wait times are lower your greatest
chance of survival with a terminal
illness is living in the United States
but people in Cuba people in Canada
think they have better health care you
are citing studies that revolve around
polls and questionnaires and again the
dropout rate is also very high that is
not as reliable or objective as
mortality rates as medically observable
data and so I think it's important if
you are going to take on the
responsibility of informing people as to
the science to differentiate between
polls and questionnaires how people feel
and what happens as far as whether they
have a pulse or not well on that sense I
would ask you to find a study that
objectively actually states that's a
suicide Ally actually remains the same
pre and post comparing pre to post a or
goes up post I don't think you can find
any study that does that if you can
please tell me because I'd love to know
there are a couple studies that I
asked several other conservatives to
write on transgender issues to Italy you
know if you know of any please provide
them I'd be willing to read them but
there's a no study that shows
suicidality goes up when comparing pre
to post there it's never been never said
it goes up well or stays the same it's
it doesn't get much better is a point
there could be some studies that show a
slight improvement but generally
speaking it's still much higher than the
general population it's not even close I
think there you're making a qualitative
analysis ting ssin there because it does
get better regardless I mean there's
some that show less than others I mean
that's you're playing with numbers there
no not really I think if you if you say
they have a 41% to attempted suicide
rate if you have a study like the
Swedish day that you mentioned where it
goes up about it's still 19 times higher
than the general population regardless
of the information that you discussed
after 25 year follow-up there's also a
more recent Canadian study that came
from Toronto I believe where was about
18 times more likely to commit suicide
than in general population these are
post-operative transgenders so again
this matters because across it's
consistent we're ok here you've got 19
times here you've got a tee-time 18
times when you look at the mortality
rates the studies are pretty conclusive
now it doesn't mean that all of them are
going to show the exact same number but
18 19 times that's more consistent in
the studies you mentioned one of which
is funded by a transgender activist
group that had a 30% down to 5 percent
and then you said a new Canadian study
says it's down to 1% I mean most people
would look at that and it doesn't it
doesn't pass a sniff test again I think
you're looking at it in a vacuum because
there are also studies that have
measured not just transition but other
factors because the the high suicide
rate as other trans activists will tell
you doesn't just come from gender
dysphoria it also comes from the way
they were treated and people we're
treated in the population and we
actually have looking at one study right
here transphobic violence showed strong
associations with suicidality
it showed that 56% had considered
suicide in the past year and 29%
attempted contrasting 28 had considered
and four had attempted who hadn't
experienced transphobic harassment
threats or violence
so I mean you're looking at it in a
vacuum and we can't really look at
things in a vacuum we can just look at
all this data you can kind of
make conclusions we're kind of going
closing and closing and closing the gap
with all the data we're seeing but the
closing of the gap is going in the
direction that it helps not that it
doesn't so I mean if you want that to be
your position that there's not enough
data I mean that's completely fine and
no no no my opposition my and I want to
make it really clear first off I think I
want to reiterate I think that you want
to improve the quality of life for
transgenders and I think you want
society to be as functional and tolerant
as possible I believe that's your
objective and that's certainly my
objective so no my position isn't
there's not enough data I want to be
very clear because I know a lot of times
people will have people from opposing
viewpoints and sort of feign middle
ground no my position is that there is
such overwhelming data right now that
it's not good now what you just said
there I do agree with of course people
who are bullied people who are
mistreated people who are abused
probably have increased rates of
suicidality I think we would both agree
with that but the truth is that minority
groups in general actually have lower
suicide rates for example blacks
compared to whites I don't think anyone
here would say that black people are
less likely to be victims of hate crimes
no where else do you find the attempted
suicide rate in society outside of
modern transgenderism and wanting what's
best for them wanting a higher quality
of life I don't think that pumping
people with hormones or going through
sexual risa it's it's clearly not the
solution that's my my stance here's
where I want to correct you on looking
at other minorities and why that doesn't
make sense
the LGBT community is the only minority
where a lot of that transphobic abuse is
actually coming from inside their very
own family it's not just society I mean
blacks aren't giving other black people
within their family racism it's it or if
it is it's extremely rare but the the
amount of abuse and violence that you
even see against LGBT people within
their own family is much much higher and
so you have to see that in context as
well um okay a couple of things there I
disagree I think you see all kinds of
abuse for example in black American
families let alone fatherlessness and
and then it
be true across the board with you just
kind of lump it all in and we've had a
lot of gay activists on this program who
don't like the LGBTQ a AIP now and I'm
sure you don't like some of the parts
that are being added to the acronym is
as the t they don't like the t just sort
of piggybacking on the LGB they don't
have the same suicide rates gays and
lesbians it's not even close it's
exclusive to the transgender community
and if you look at paranoid
schizophrenics that's where you would
have a similar suicide rate you don't
see it in any other minority group
including by the way minority groups
throughout history who were low fully
abused so um I just I don't I I don't
think that holds water
I wanted to crease a suicide rate but I
don't think it's because they're being
ostracized by society well I mean also
when you're looking at the time frame of
1973 to 1988 versus 1989 to 2011 you
also have to admit that things have
gotten a lot better civil rights wise
for the LGBT community so again you
can't look at it in a vacuum and just
say well American slaves long have the
same suicide rate they didn't have the
same kind of abuse from within their
family
very rarely from within their family
their own family they didn't they often
didn't know who their family was they
get the bowl up every now and then from
whitey in a cotton field of Missouri and
be fortunate I know is not Pro sling I'm
not endorsing either I'm just saying
that yeah it's not a fair comparison
that's all I'm saying okay I think it's
a very unfair comparison to American
slaves yeah I think they had it much
worse than transgenders in 2018 well I I
I actually would agree okay I I I
definitely agree on that I think things
are getting better I mean we have more
healthcare so we do have it better than
slaves back then why did we get into
this well I'm just saying because you
were talking about suicide rates and and
again I'm using an extreme example to
make a point in its the point is is
still made nowhere else do you see this
kind of a suicide right and I think that
matters when you say things like and I
know your well actually this would be a
perfect transition to the next topic
right I know I think you've you've
criticized my position when you say
let's give kids
Burtie blockers or hormone replacement
therapy when you say the solution is
gender reassignment surgery and you're
looking at a suicide rate that doesn't
really get better even in the face of
these wildly invasive procedures and
interventions at some point we have to
say okay maybe this isn't the solution
and because I want a higher quality of
life for transgender people across the
board that's why I line up the way I do
that's why I think that gender dysphoria
should be treated a different way
outside of hormones injections or
plastic surgery so that brings up one
point just before we move on to the next
thing which if you have again I've asked
several other conservatives including
Ryan Anderson who just wrote a book on
transgender issues and he can't answer
this either if you want trans people are
people with gender dysphoria to be
treated with a different medical
treatment sure you have to provide
evidence that that medical treatment
actually consistently and effectively
alleviates gender dysphoria and you
don't have that there is no study that
shows alternative treatments have been
shown to consistently and effectively
treat gender dysphoria and alleviated
and we've had reparative therapy and you
know neither do you those in therapy
that's a big point not neither do you
what you're presenting here doesn't help
and there certainly are some issues
actually that I would present we're
talking about children there are issues
that completely alleviated actually as
far as adult trans transgenders you know
I don't know that I necessarily have the
solution but but neither do you so I
think at that point err on the side of
caution and not pumping you know a guy
full of estrogen which we know has these
negative ramifications incredibly
negative side effects and with children
yeah there are ways to completely
alleviate it with children and teens so
I would like to transition to two that
we can go back to that if you'd like oh
yeah go right ahead it's your show no
but what's your position on on
transitioning children IFIF for people
who don't know I I'm against it I think
it's child abuse sure I think we have to
really stick by the dsm-5 and W path
associ standards I don't think it's as
simple as every kid who says that
they're transgender immediately futility
blockers hormones I think everybody kids
have to be assessed based on the highest
quality standards
and the problem is that I know you're
about to bring up these system studies
but they were
all done and there's actually reviews
that have been done specifically on the
literature and dr. steensma who is the
most quoted study on assistance has come
out and said those those figures that he
cites are misleading because no can you
provide the figures because actually I
don't have those studies in front of me
which one dr. steensma I think that was
one that you said I was going to use I
don't have any I don't believe I have
any plans to oh I don't have that one
specifically I have quote from dr.
steensma but usually people cite it as
80% assistance okay um but steensma has
number one he's actually said that
providing these distant numbers only
leads to the wrong can I ask you a
question before we go what's your
position on so you said higher standards
okay so how should we standardize for
children to be given hormone replacement
therapy or puberty blockers what is a
standard to be set and what age do you
think it is I want to make sure we're
not arguing over something that maybe we
don't disagree on so what is what would
be your stance there
oh absolutely well first of all you know
puberty blockers before Tanner stage 2
that's based on the W path associ and
the dsm-5 and ER stage 2 puberty has
actually already started no psychiatrist
or endocrinologist even trans positive
or affirming ones will provide or should
provide puberty blockers before stanner
stage 2 because that usually happens
between ages 9 to 11 so it's not like
we're putting three or four year-olds I
completely disagree that that would
happen
usually you've wait a couple years make
sure that that is right
the puberty blockers are right yeah HRT
typically comes around thirteen fourteen
if they started puberty blockers early
if they started puberty blockers later
you know give them time to figure it out
the point about affirming therapy so I
want to make clear between nine and
eleven is the age you're talking about
to start puberty blockers correct but
I'm not again I'm not just saying
anybody who goes in and says sure no I
understand I just wanna make sure
because I disagree regardless I want to
make sure my position is clear in your
and then yeah but can but continue I
just want to make sure we understood
that premise there because it is it is a
sliding scale right some people do go a
lot younger and some people go older
some people go as far as 16 and it is
sometimes it seems arbitrary to me I
just wanted to make sure I had your
position clear no I mean I don't think
it's necessarily arbitrary I think it's
individualized to people I mean people
don't go puberty go through puberty at
the same time and they shouldn't be
giving puberty blockers at the same time
either I mean I didn't start shaving my
till I was 20 my wife jokes that she put
hair in my chest I didn't grow chest
hair until my 20s so yeah I was a late
bloomer and an angry late bloomer
hence what you see before you but yes
sorry continue
oh so the point is I do support
affirming therapy but the thing about
affirming therapy is that a lot of
people have at least on your side I'll
say conservative side I don't want to
assume your side I am conservative
that's fine I appreciate it though okay
that affirming therapy is taking kids
down a path of transition and that's not
the point of affirming therapy actually
the entire point of the affirming
approach is to give kids and youth the
space to explore their identity and
expression and sometimes that leads to
transitions sometimes it doesn't I mean
we have cases of kids who went on
puberty blockers found that it wasn't
the right thing came off when through
puberty is normal perfectly fine
realized it wasn't for them so that's
that's not what you're doing with
affirming therapy and that's what I
don't I don't think anybody should be
pushed one way or another I don't think
kids should be told you're transgender
versus I don't think kids should be told
you're not transgender I think we should
listen monitor yes let them lead but do
so based on rigorous scientific
standards I think it's a horrible idea
I think letting children lead is a bad
idea all around I don't think we don't
let children lead and deciding what they
have for lunch
if it were me and I were in charge of
any of my own decision-making abilities
my breakfast would be nothing but
toaster strudels and boogers I'd wipe in
the couch the night previously so the
study that I was talking about
beforehand I think or or that I was what
I was thinking about you mentioned
someone else cheetah or something know
of the shrinking thing of the the
Drescher
I think Drescher and Paula Drescher it's
somewhere around 2013 2014 yeah 70
five to ninety percent of children with
gender dysphoria just completely grow
out of it completely grow out of it so
seventy five to ninety percent so I'm
actually using some it's a little lower
I think you mentioned something around
eighty five percent so I think that's
why the standards are so important
especially we're talking about putting
children on who puberty blockers and and
especially he talked about you know
endocrinologist the the connection
between neurology and hormones is
unbelievably powerful and we're talking
at a rapid stage where the brain is
developing and it directly correlates to
hormonal transitioning so 75% to 90% of
children with gender dysphoria or nine
to eleven year olds will grow out will
grow out of it completely
and of course avoid that that super high
suicide rate avoid all of the you know
systemic oppression discrimination that
you've talked about even though I would
totally disagree with people who
mistreat transgenders but the point is
it's about seventy five to ninety
percent that number goes down to zero if
you actually put them on puberty
blockers well okay so there are several
different things you're bringing in here
so let me just go one by one really
quick the first thing is that all those
studies were looking at dsm for
diagnostics which is actually gender
identity disorder which completed a
gender non-conforming behavior with
gender dysphoria the dsm-5 actually
separates them diagnostically as two
completely different things
a kid who is gender non-conforming or
has gender non-conforming behavior under
the dsm-5 would not qualify for medical
transition in any sort of form unless
they're above age of medicals consent
but then we get into questions of
informed consent those are getting the
questions a flit association of science
talked about because in china it's still
considered a mental disorder to be gay
and there is a lot of politics at play
right now with the dsm-5 and also I
noticed that the transgender community
brings out things they like about the
dsm-5 and some things that they don't
like about the dsm-5 but the data that
we have objectively available to us
shows that the vast majority of children
who suffer from gender dysphoria or who
identify as someone of the opposite
gender grow out of it well let me get
back to your zero percent because I
think that's very very important
because the kids for the most part right
now who are being given puberty blockers
have been diagnosed with gender
dysphoria based on the dsm-5
specifically which means that they are
not likely to desist so you're making a
distinction that going on puberty
blockers
is what's causing not assistants God why
do I consistent he's not assistance ah I
understand the what you're talking about
can you basically saying do-over I know
I was wrong that's what we're talking
about it's okay with the nomenclature
yeah Noah no I'm not I am talking about
people identify as a member of the
opposite gender versus people who get
put on puberty blockers so let's say
then I have a 75 to 90 percent number
again the study will go up at PubMed
let's say the number is 50% the point is
you talked about standards right saying
not anyone who just claims to be who
claims to be transgender should be
allowed to undergo this treatment but
the fact is these are the same people v
let's say 50% but it's 75 to 90 who go
back and say well you know what I was
wrong about that completely grew out of
it these are the same people where it's
a zero percent rate if they undergo
puberty blockers which again would
suggest it's too early in the
developmental stages for these kids to
make a decision and at nine to 11 which
is what you cited I would absolutely say
that someone that age is in no position
to lead and they should be given no
authority whatsoever regarding permanent
sexual decisions or even temporary
puberty blockers as it's being sold now
well again you're going by dsm-4
standards which the vast majority even
the person who put the dsm-4 standards
in place dr. Zucker in Canada pretty
much stated that the reason he changed
the DSM 3 standards which actually fell
more towards gender dysphoria into the
DSM 4 standards which conflated gender
non-conforming behavior with gender
dysphoria is so he could pathologize
gender non-conforming kids and I
completely disagree and trans activist
completely disagree with gender
nonconforming kids who are who don't
have gender dysphoria getting treatment
but the problem is those 75% how do you
measure it I we look because again
you're getting off on this you get you
get this is we're getting really
nitpicky I addition I want to make it
clear I don't think they're going to
convince anyone here when you use the
number 9 to 11
I don't agree in any capacity period
that they should be allowed to undergo
any kind of hormonal transitions or
puberty blockers but you're saying okay
how do we differentiate that what are
the standards kid comes in and says I'm
transgender how do you say they're not
you I'm not a psychiatrist
not a psychologist but we have very
clear dsm-5 standards that require a
minimum of six months of observation
before even being able to get to that
diagnostic standard so we can put up the
dsm-5 standards and I'd be glad to send
that over to so yes your audience can
see that too so that they can make the
decision for themselves and they can see
the standards I think they can see the
standards and ice that's another thing I
think very very important because you
can go to five different psychiatrist
and get five different diagnoses these
no matter what it is whether it's
bipolar disorder whether it's ADHD
whether it's depression I mean
antidepressants have less than a than a
50% success rate a lot of them so it's
not necessarily a science that's been
completely honed in so even if I go
along with you on that trail it's
certainly not a roll of the dice I'd be
willing to make with nine to eleven year
olds putting them on puberty blockers
but if there's anything else I guess in
that topic that you'd like to explore so
I don't want to go back and forth on
just DSM for dsm-5 because like I said I
want to be clear I'm not okay with any
of it any 9 to 11 year old anyone under
the age of 18 if they cannot actually
rent a car because their brain isn't
fully developed if their insurance just
through the roof because their brain
isn't fully developed I don't support
altering their hormones well I mean
again I'm not going to go back to it but
something to consider is that if you
don't want us to treat gender gender
dysphoria q thwip the with the standards
that there are medical studies that show
that it works how do you want to treat
them and are you just going to not treat
them and let them suffer from depression
and suicidality i mean that's that's
kind of the the where you're going out
of here yes but okay as far as far as
priority as far as puberty blockers yes
I would not treat them I would
absolutely treat them with therapy of
course I try to teach them to live with
but you know we always talk about kids
accepting themselves for who they are I
know we're gonna get into a great
territory well who they are is really
secretly a woman trapped in a man's body
or a girl trapped in a boy's body
I would certainly use therapy and try to
get them to come to grips with the
biological reality if they're a boy or a
girl
then I would administering puberty
blockers to nine or eleven year olds yes
open bands particular okay and and again
kind of where I was coming with that is
for your side if you want to convince
people on my side is actually go through
studies of treating kids with that
method
and let's see if it works if it's
medically found to be working maybe you
have a point
I think abuse I wouldn't I wouldn't just
like I wouldn't be willing to you know
test or a test radioactive material on
children that could harm them and say
well we'll have a study listen it's the
same reason it's really hard to get cans
pharmaceutical drugs for cancer right to
get approved a lot of people think it's
big farmer there's a there's a certain
component of that but people who are on
death death death row effectively with
cancer people in their deathbed death
from using a symbolically people use
neuter between death row you know what
I'm not talking about people on the
Green Mile but people on their death bed
with cancer aren't necessarily willing
to risk taking a placebo pill I'm not
willing to risk experimental treatment
with children and hormone blockers
period me either and that's where we
agree but we're coming at it from
different places we we both agree that
we don't want experiment on children but
we both see it from a different sides
okay okay now the one thing I wanted to
get back to you on brains is we actually
do have plenty of studies that have
studied pre pre treatment trans people
comparing them to cisgender people and
found that those brain differences occur
before treatment it's not something that
just occurs with HRT or with surgery
it's something that is ingrained and
there studies that are showing it there
was a study released earlier this year
that again I'll cite in the in the video
that showed it in kids under 10 that
those differences in the brain where
they looked at trans girls and found
that the brains were more similar to
those of cisgender girls and trans boys
sis boys equally so it's not just
something that happens with treatment
it's something that is innate in a
certain sense okay I I would disagree
but I do appreciate you presenting this
because it seems to me that you two may
be making the argument that
transgenderism is not gender its
biological it's it's it's sex there's a
there's a male brain in a female brain
would seem to be the the premise of of
your position there so here's here's the
point that I want to make because I find
that a lot of people conflate it and
this is one of the problems I have with
the term gender identity is that when we
talk about gender identity people look
at the word gender and say well gender
is cultural why do you have to why are
you saying it has to do anything with
biology the problem is that the term
gender identity actually income
is aspects of biological sex and gender
it's not just gender so it's a little
misleading although I just wanted to
point that out because I know that comes
out a lot that came out on Twitter this
morning I think I was having a
discussion with somebody that said
gender identity is culture it's like no
gender identity is a lot more discussion
is being very generous when applying it
to Twitter there was a a typing shouting
match but yeah it's not much productive
discussion takes place on Twitter okay
well I appreciate that because that's
certainly not what's taught in college
they've really tried to separate sex and
gender I mean obviously you've seen when
we did the change my mind people say
well sex is entirely biological gender
is cultural and it seems to me that
you're saying that's that's not entirely
accurate and it's it's it's not really a
fair way to present the argument as is
currently being presented well I I don't
think you can see it it's black and
white either I here's the problem gender
identity as a term doesn't just
encompass so there is gender and there
is sex but the term gender identity
doesn't just mean gender and the problem
is by having the term gender identity
you're conflating it with gender and no
it's actually a combination of gender
and sex so it's a that's why I say it's
myths okay so that so then I guess
before we get into the Nitty Gritty of
studies how would you say that let's say
a male to female transgender has a
female brain or a female to male
transgender has a male brain pre sex
hormone replacement therapy I mean you
can look at the studies it's pretty much
neurons gray matter all these different
structures right so here's the thing I
think I I agree with you I agree with
you I'm saying there are definitively
male brains and female brains there
they're definitively different right I
think we both realize why make sure we
agree okay yeah and that's that's kind
of one of the problems that I have with
some of the what they call themselves
radical feminists or something where
they say it's like oh there's no
difference between brains it's like bull
bull crap there's differences between
male and female brains and that's that
but to - to me that's why trans people
exist is because there are they're just
differences I always use the the Joker
meme it's like tell people that genitals
are sexually dimorphic and nobody bats
an eye but tell people that brains are
sexually dimorphic as well and everybody
loses
their goddamn minds yeah I well I
appreciate your consistency there
because obviously it the whole argument
collapses because you can't say that
there's that someone identifies as a
male or a female if gender is entirely
socially constructed but then also imply
that they have the wrong brain trapped
in the wrong body because I'm all second
is that biological as a gender socially
constructed so I do appreciate your
consistency there and I think that so if
I wanted to clarify that because I think
it's different from a lot of Pro sort of
transgender activist cohorts who just
really muddy the waters and I think it's
confusing to a lot of people when they
try to make their argument and I think
yours is certainly more consistent in
your position based on that is that
there are the studies outweigh the sort
of um I guess you'd say that they you
think there are more studies and not
that show that the the changes in brain
in in one's brain occur before hormone
replacement therapy yeah we have enough
because I think when you were on with I
talk a lot with Zack Ford and when you
were on with Zack you mentioned a study
that was only looking at post to make it
up to make a sort of a conclusion and
you can't really do that you have to
look pre versus post because even that
study was coming to the conclusion that
well this difference might have been pre
but we weren't looking at people pretty
and so we have to actually take studies
again I think you're talking about the
loot the the looters study right mm-hmm
okay yeah so I mean we have to use the
same methodology and look preed to pose
to actually come to a definitive
conclusion we can't just take arbitrary
sure thank you well and I do think it's
important to note that that you know
these conversations don't exist in a
vacuum sometimes people say well you
know you took that study and it
contradicts for your position when the
hall and second we were referencing that
study at the time because of the topic
being discussed with Zack Ford those
aren't the only studies that we've
referenced on this show again we're very
transparent about our sources I do think
you're right that you do need to compare
pre and post and the study that I think
we've used in this show quite a bit more
is the SAVAK and Arbor study that
actually shows that know the changes
occurred after and that they didn't
believe in the the dogma that um that
transgender brains are somehow different
before any kind of hormone replacement
therapy so that's that's one I think
again it's at PubMed people can find it
I believe it's Saavik and harbor there
is another one that published
20-18 that found action funny enough
funny enough something that boat might
have surprised both of us at some
variations and transgender brains
actually we're a byproduct of
environment and culture not vice-versa
so there are quite a few studies out
there that would actually sort of under
undermine your premise
yeah and I'm always you know look at the
data make up your own mind but I think
medical organizations are going to make
up their mind based on the studies they
have in the conclusions that those
studies have drawn and while all the
studies are showing one sort of
perspective and one conclusion in all or
kind of regardless of how big or how
small they are they're kind of coming to
the same conclusion again I get that you
disagree but while they come to that
same conclusion they're going to set
their standards a certain way and that's
why if you and this is kind of where I'm
gonna tell you if you want to win if
your side wants to change medical
standards what you need to no no we're
not we're not the ones who change
medical standards let me make that
really clear here the transgender
community is we're not changing medical
standards I think the medical stands see
that's where I I kind of go a little
back because I think the medical
standards are fine as is I mean now the
AMA the APA the
gosh what am I thinking of pretty much
every major medical organization on the
planet is not is has pretty much said
that all the studies show that
transition actually does help alleviate
generated I think I think you're doing
better until you got to they said pretty
much all the major medical organizations
in the world all the studies completely
incorrect I'm sorry but if heads your
bets they're a little let's say there
are a lot of medical groups that take
some studies and they have concluded
that but all major medical organizations
say that all the studies no I mean in
this this one alone I've listed you five
or six or seven or eight all of which
have much larger sample sizes much lower
dropout rates and rely on objective data
as opposed to questionnaires so to say
all medical organizations
aside from Johns Hopkins that's a hate
group out there agree on all the studies
it's just not accurate that's not
accurate to say well I'd actually like
to see one major medical organization
that says that transitioning doesn't
help and if you're gonna say the what's
the the pediatricians the College of PDA
C peds there at there are not going by
the science I mean and we'll see this
and this is what you're doing with your
with your research is well I would say
you cherry pick we go well they're not
going by the science as a sign the
science that I've established you're the
science that I agree with they're not
going Johns Hopkins is not going with
our science therefore all of the studies
agree with me no I just presented more
then you've presented with bigger
sampling sizes and more objective data
again mortality rates are more objective
than questionnaires and that's what's
important and when you look at the
objective studies and parameters first
off I would even say I would even give
you this there are some that there are
conflicting studies I would even give
you that but you seem so secure in the
data that you've presented which largely
is based on polling in questionnaires
and eliminated any scientific data that
disagrees with your position I don't
think you're going to convince anyone
and I I think that's a real problem it's
not my job listen to win people over to
the idea that if you're born
chromosomally a man and with a penis
that you know undergoing a sex
reassignment surgery doesn't make you a
woman
it's not my job to prove that it's never
been my job to prove that and I think if
you're going to prove it definitively
and tell people they need to know
they're not educated on the science you
have to do better than cherry-picking
some studies there's only one person
here is presented studies that were
funded by trans activist groups or well
any kind of a group that would have a
political bias and it's been yourself
there's only been one person here's
presented studies that rely on
questionnaires or subjective data or
polling and that's been yourself and I
think that's important so then they make
the statement that all major medical
organizations agree on all the studies
that is the issue that's not
intellectually honest I think we could
both agree on that that statement okay
i'll all all admit that saying all is
probably a little facetious okay I'll
say the majority okay now here's the
thing with Johns Hopkins I want to just
point out really quick the study that
Paul McHugh did that in the 70s that
determined that transitioning doesn't
help he was actually using his own
biases so let me just give you an
example and I'll tell you like
for myself I am a transgender woman who
went through surgery and everything but
I still have relationships with women I
am a lesbian I like women according to
Paul McHugh I would have a negative non
lesser quality of life standard based on
the study that he used to us End
transition treatment at Johns Hopkins so
I definitely want to say people look at
the study that Paul McHugh is using
right used in the 70s to stop the
transition treatment it's a little more
complex than he found that it didn't
help he was using his own biases to
determine that yes and by the way I want
to be clear I was I was referring them
because a lot of people I know have
referred to them as a hate group I
didn't reference any of their studies
here today but I would agree that
there's some bias there from him
much like the trans pulse project which
was the first one that you cited here
with a Canadian study that only studied
people one year after transitioning and
whether they felt like they wanted to
commit suicide or not all right listen
Julie right goldstein I really do
appreciate you taking the time where is
the best place for people to find you
and everyone out there be polite comment
below show your support for us having a
discussion because you want to love
about this you and I agreed on virtually
nothing it doesn't have to be common
ground or ass flurry you can completely
disagree and be civil and so I hope that
you feel the same way I've really
appreciated this conversation know that
again like I'm I'm not finding this I
think neither of us are finding this a
lot lately in the current environment
we're just not all we hear is like all
these noise and we're not having
conversations I think we need to be
doing this more often just my personal
opinion
I completely agree with them and they
can oh they can find me at Julie Rea Ju
liie REI ray REI like the store not the
pop star on Twitter all over the place
I'm an actress as you mentioned I'm the
only not only probably only or one or
two trans actors in Hollywood currently
working who has never been on a reality
show or worked as a transgender
character on a show either so I've been
on like Comedy Central and worked with
analog laser or Zach Galifianakis bunch
of really good people you can look at my
IMDB for all that stuff look at my
Twitter I make announcements there I
also stream on Twitch if you like
videa gaymes which I'm sure most of your
audience does I don't see that would be
an example where I have more of a female
brain but let me let me ask you this I
think you and I might find some common
ground there because I'm not mistaken
you know right now they're mad at
lesbian I was a lesbian Batwoman or
lesbian superwoman for not being woken
up and a lot of people get mad when
there are actors who aren't trans
playing trans characters if I'm not
mistaken you're not necessarily entirely
on board with that right well here's the
thing
I've actually been outspoken for years
about what I what what is called virtue
signaling and I actually wrote a piece
for time criticizing Mount Holyoke when
they took out the Vagina Monologues for
saying that it wasn't trans inclusive I
actually wrote a piece for time because
I'm like I've done the Vagina Monologues
for over a decade it's one of the most
trans inclusive pieces there is and even
within the horror community we have like
their haunts every October and the hunt
community there are a lot of people
within the haunt community who are
affected by mental health issues it's a
completely different topic but it seems
like people are trying to talk for other
groups and I hate that yeah just let
people talk for themselves no virtue
signaling that's why well I I appreciate
that but do you do you get aggravated if
you see an on transgender plate for
example like Jeffrey little Jeffrey
Tambor in transparent there's a tongue
twister to say let's disregard the other
he was that he was groping the craft
services lady at the table behind the
camera but where do you line up on that
because again I appreciate your
consistency there so where I come about
it is that I don't think that trans
characters should be played by sis
actors I think transit characters should
be played by trans actors and cysts
actors should only play two sisters but
the problem that I come with and from
what I see here is that the vast
majority of the roles and characters
that we see in media don't have a
specific gender identity they could very
well be trans where they could very well
be cysts and when you have a position
like that and what I advocate for is for
casting directors to bring in more trans
actors for all those other types of
roles for example I've played an Android
I played a cavewoman I played lauren
cohan sister on Tim and Eric and you
know you could say that they were trans
or you could say that they were cysts
because gender identity didn't matter
for any of the roles that I was doing
and I I'm very for more trans actor
getting into those kind of roles and
being brought in for those kind of roles
but when it is a specific trans
character or a syst character I think
that should be specific regardless of
which way you're going well I appreciate
that because it's consistent because
obviously Hollywood has had it both ways
where they've had they've had six
characters played by transgender actors
sometimes and then when you go the other
way it has to be a transgender actor III
would I would you know what I would go
with you and then so if those were the
rules okay just think everyone's a
little bit murky on the rule book and
now even they're trying to retroactively
Lee rewrite the rules on who can play
gay characters in that case Angley would
have never won an Oscar all right at
julie ray ju li e ray ar e Julie right
goldstein thank you for taking the time
today we really do appreciate it and I
hope you hope you stay stay happy safe
healthy haha thanks Steven you too take
it easy if you like this video subscribe
or click the notification bell right
next to the subscription but because
absque rhyming doesn't mean anything
anymore now according to the YouTube
gods and if you liked the late night
show you can watch it every single day a
full hour at lot with credit com / mug
clubs subscribe there that way we aren't
beholden to the evil YouTube overlords
and we don't have to start playing video
games with mouth sound effects or
children react